pretese pensando è piaciuto talmente
tanto la gente che mi hanno fatto una no
non hanno fatti i due non hanno fatti
tre non perdendo patti 49 ma seriamente
hanno fatti sei in realtà perché è
uscito sta roba indovinate chi è povero
stronzo che deve giocarsi fanno gli
smantellano i [ __ ] cazzi tuoi
lorenzo freddi fibers pizzeria cerchi
pizzeria simulator non lo so che cos'è
parole dallo stesso creatore di finance
trade scrive un fan made l'ha fatto
proprio il creatore di fi ne del freddi
e ci sono dei bambini brutti quindi
giochiamo presenter nisa in pizza voto
pizzeria chironi spaghetti mamamia
design e pizza design your pizza si stop
insua dentro pitts peperoni peperoncino
pizzoli woogie tutto mettiamo tutto sto
punto peperoncini che sembrano carini e
basta per il ver so se non troppa troppa
roba la pizza con la bue nava star
napoletana 28 pizzeria bene ma non è la
mia pizza non l'ho fatta così vasta
scala
cosa mai fatta fire connect pizza move
vs di troppi sasha posso tirare la pizza
con cinque dei germi che ai creatori di
fai da tè freddi se ha fatto questo
scempio mag e che ha però apprezzo
perché almeno ge noa già perché io
lancio per lanciarla pitosto
schiacciando shift e quindi i tasti
permanenti di stop
vienna no non riesco perché il mouse mi
rimane al centro dello schermo porca
basta giocare col cos'è sta roba
adesso lui mi fa da buffon mi parla mi
par alle pizze tieni e freddi magna
destra pasta dio perché avete scelto
shift come tasto di per lanciarle pit
per farmi girare la rogna vero che hai
dovrebbe essere a posto fi no
perfetto sia finito round 4
oh mio dio cosa vedo
l'arca vacchia oddio cosa sta succedendo
gesù aiuto esorcizza il mio computer di
frey ecco questa quando disattivi tasti
permanenti di windows succede questo
grazie casa
buongiorno ha proprio una a questi che
sono il professore lo studente che mi
porta la verifica allora signorina
federica che incazzatissima vediamo di
leggere le cose allora la capitale del
bangladesh e torino no sbagliato anche
questo non si è capaci quanto fa due più
due risposte chiedi a giulia penna no ho
sbagliato anche questo non sia capace a
fare come mai studiato note aggiuntive
niente quindi va bene così posto poi
andare andare a sederti al banco
jobs che anche perché c'è un cane che va
lavoro
io non mi sono preso jobs che per un
attimo ero convinto come se stesse
aprendo un franchise di del ristorante
di freddy quindi io ho aperto il mio
ristorante i miei animatronics c
verresti tutti a mangiare da me è vero
si curano 100 dollari
mi hanno lasciato 100 dollari per creare
il mio ristorante a colorful questo
prendiamo i piatti colorati stai zitto
so come farlo mamma mia quanto sono
inquietanti psicosi però li compro
lostan 5 dollari per il mio ristorante
assoluta vj's 5 stelle michelin prenderà
una piscina di papere mi sembra ovvio
altri alberi aver messo a posto
posizionarle addirittura ma chi
animatronic dove sono esattamente i
video comprare pure quelli sponsorship
hoffer a che figata di sponsor calcetto
sono un venduto per l'attaccante sponsor
nel mio ristorante amene catalogo è la
madonna che casca saint martin garics il
prossimo ospite
siamo partiti così questo è il mio
ristorante quindi devo completare le mie
mansioni mentre sono in ufficio un tasto
bene il mio computer fa casino e quindi
per evitare che le succeda qualcosa io
posso spegnerlo in qualsiasi momento
posso anche spegnere il sistema di
ventilazione per evitare che gente mi
salti addosso perché ti devi appendere
dei disegni così perché ti vuoi fare del
male fisico spiega mi devo aspettare che
finiscano le cose quindi a fantastico a
posto io devo cliccare su ogni cosa e
sperare che finiscano prima che qualcuno
mi salta in faccia va bene
[Musica]
carina ballo sapevo che tanto prima per
sarebbe successo lo sapevo porca vacca
mi sembra troppo bello per essere vero
gesù buon dio 38 visitatori ho avuto 257
dollari
bene ecco il primo giorno non è male ma
aragami servirebbe un animatronic è da
comprare che sono un casino lo compriamo
la prossima volta per adesso va bene
questo il tavolo dal tub di pac man mano
non so se ho visto bene farmi mettere il
tavolo di pac man
perché lui e l'ho messo beh non è male
dai soli e playtest a posso giocarci
pure madama che storia c'è una fascia
che continua a fissarmi mentre gioco mio
zio brutta cosa
cioè non è la più brutta che abbiate mai
visto sì per me se time is up a cosa è
servito tutto questo spiegano cosa cosa
creato la più niente spesso ci può però
vediamo martis lunger mio dio va bene
grazie martis così posso comprarmi 2
animatronics quella tra sponsorizzazione
va bene vediamo mega acquisto di 800
cose oggi su buon dio non mi appare pure
l'altro sponsor quello che ho preso
prima
no perché se mi appare anche quello me
ne vado
marty sprunger ma perché non mi deve
apparire a me che cosa me ne frega a me
che il mio sponsor
mettilo nel locale non a me stampa
volantini stampa poster stampa menù
tutto questo nel mentre che mi stanno
per stuprare l'anno se il computer a 60
gradi in teoria possono spegnere la
ventilazione così da sentire se c'è
qualcuno nel sistema di ventole altro di
tutto questo che bello è il pupazzo ha
anche non sapevo potesse fare queste
cose
mancano solo queste tre cose raga poi ho
finito solo questa manca solo questa 200
log off
ho 43 visitor stavolta hanno fatto di
più 300 dollari mammamia aimone italia
non è graviamo che la metà basta ragazzi
andiamo a comprare un anima troni
proviamo a prendere nel fair che è il
più classico tra tutti proprio il
classico un'anima tron è dio sbloccato
un nuovo store intanto e vabbè la
madonna quanto fico aiuto era l'ultimo
store che cosa vendono le montagne russe
rockstar freddi 2.000 dollari costa
fredda la madonna dato con quello che ho
già gridato di brutto il mio ristorante
mai così col freddi bagaglio freddi
cinese ma va bene così massa si può fare
un altro sponsor e l'amato a 1.000
dollari
va bene mi sembra veramente [ __ ] quindi
mettiamo da qualche parte stiamo al
posto della del barile stupido latest
perché poi giocarci con il bari ma come
spiega mi devo fare gioco dell'anno raga
meraviglioso sempre comunque il gioco
migliore di cat mario eri getting over
it e perché claiming to mi detti delle
cose io devo cercare noi e nel mentre so
cosa mi può saltare in faccia lo devo
fermare ok già spiegato un taser mi ha
detto che ne avevo tre adesso ne avrò
solo due in meno al mese
[Musica]
se gli aveva anche prima gli occhi
aperti one sapevo perché aperto gli
occhi ha aperto gli occhi non me ne sono
accorto bene qui great job tua madre o
gesù
l'ultima e basta poi perché mi chiami
mette nasse incredibile sta roba order
caps tutti i casinò di nuovo va bene
[Musica]
perche
sto guardando se c'è gente nei condotti
non puoi mettermi lì mi sponsor
attenzione questo gioco utilizza rumori
alti flash lime light and jump square lo
dici adesso va bene ragazzi per adesso
direi che possiamo concludere quale il
bello comunque traente camera mi sono
fatto il mio ristorantino non poche gare
però meno mi piace che scrivete e
sappiate chi non forma il direttore di
un ristorante
questo è poco ma sicuro vabbè
[Musica]